[Music]
hey cousin today I'm sharing my favorite
dessert arroz con leche Or Hispanic rice
pudding I add five cups of water to a
pot along with five to six sweet cloves
three cinnamon sticks and a piece of
lime peel I cover and let this boil for
10 minutes then I add one cup of washed
rice combine and lower the flame to low
I covered for 25 minutes until the rice
absorbs most of the water I removed the
lime peel and I add one cup of coconut
milk half cup of evaporated milk one cup
of sweetened condensed milk a teaspoon
of salt one of vanilla I combine and I
add in some raisins this part is
optional this is still going on a low
flame and I cover for 20 minutes when
the time is up I remove the top milk
layer give it a good mix and this cream
and velvety arroz con leche is done I
like mine at room temperature but hot or
cold it still goes enjoy cousin